time then for the press preview it's our
first look at what is on the front of
tuesday's papers
in the next 20 minutes or so we'll see
what's making the headlines tonight with
the journalist and author ella wieland
and the columnist and broadcaster
steve richard good evening to both of
you speak to you in a moment
first of all let's take a look at some
of those front pages for you we'll start
with the metro
the final lock down is what they go with
the words of boris johnson of course
that when he eases the third national
coveted lockdown and does it properly
he hopes it will be for the last time
the daily telegraph also makes
that its lead story the times reports on
new figures that suggest covid19
vaccines
cut transmission of the virus onto the
eye it's reporting on the new hotel
quarantine for people arriving from
redless countries with some passengers
complaining
of a lack of segregation for higher risk
arrivals
the guardian reports on allegations that
former downing street advisor dominic
cummings
was involved in the decision to award a
government kovic contract to some of his
friends
here's the ft leading with jaguar land
rover's decision to make all of its
vehicles electric by
2030. the mirror leads on the duke and
duchess of sussex's interview with u.s
chat show host oprah winfrey calling it
a royal
soap opera quite clever while the star
pours more scorn on the sussex is saying
their decision might cause a bit of a
kerfuffle
and i'm joined tonight by the journalist
and author hello and columnist and
broadcaster steve
richards great to see you both thanks
for being with us um well it's been
quite a day
hasn't it and it's certainly reflected
on all the front pages
ella why don't we start with the front
of the telegraph
johnson this must be the final lock down
at the prime minister being extremely
cautious
yeah well the interesting thing is it
that
the message from boris johnson is kind
of being portrayed in two ways so on the
one hand
there's a kind of there's this cautious
tone to it
there's the suggestion that this isn't
going to be something that's going to
magically happen overnight that we're
not going to see restrictions lift
automatically that there is going to be
very much a step-by-step
process a staggered approach and then on
the other hand
so what i mean is that's kind of in some
ways depressing because i think lots of
us
are hoping for a dramatic change at some
point we're kind of
we we just want to get back to normal as
it were and then on the other hand
there's a kind of excitement in some of
the front pages
uh tonight about the prospect of of
things reopening and
you know the telegraph says that hopes
begins its column with saying hopes were
dampened of a rapid reopening in time
for easter
and that is kind of we have to maintain
some kind of sense of perspective i
think in all of this
because while boris johnson has said
that this might be the final this must
be the final lockdown
without sounding petty and without
downplaying the challenges that the
government has faced in the last
year coming up to a year now we do have
to remember that we've heard this before
and new strains notwithstanding the
government has form
on rowing back on promises that it's
made whether it be
to lift restrictions as soon as vaccine
targets are met or whether it be to
um promise to have schools reopened i
think we should tread carefully
and into reading any kind of any kind of
excitement among ourselves into what
boris johnson is saying
that being said i think actually in a
positive way the pressure is on
by the successes of the government in
fact the success the fantastic success
of the vaccine rollout
has meant that it the prospect of us
opening up is
plausible now it isn't crazy to say that
we might start making
plans for may and june july of summer
holidays that actually normal life is
within reach and so i think we should
try and reinvigorate a sense of why that
is important
of why actually we should put the last
year behind us yeah um
steve um i mean the government has had
its fingers burnt before
hasn't it and boris johnson clearly very
keen not to over promise
and under deliver would you say this
approach is is is the right one
in fairness to boris johnson when he
made the point about this being he hopes
the last lockdown
it was to justify caution belatedly
from him uh in explaining why they were
going to move cautiously out of this
lockdown
because he didn't want another but of
course he was asked how can you
guarantee there'll be no lockdown
and this time compared to other times
when he said it would be the equivalent
of pulling the nuclear pushing the
nuclear button
he said he couldn't of course he
couldn't guarantee it because of the
variance and all the other problems
so he does appear to be trying
to adopt a more cautious approach the
test will come
in the coming weeks and months a week
today we'll be getting
the broad timetable from him out of this
but i think a lot of that will be vague
and rightly so
because as he said again in a change of
tone
um they need to look at the data before
making
decisions they haven't even fully
decided what they're going to do
next monday because data is still coming
in
now that is a more sensible approach it
seems to me than the sort of
reckless gung-ho let's have christmas
let's do this
let's do that um which punctuated
2020. uh let's see it'll be under huge
political pressure
to go much faster but so far
because he wants this to be the last
slot down he's moving quite cautiously
yeah we're bringing the front of the
metro ella i can see you that you you're
desperate to get in there so just so
just
make your point uh no i mean link
linking to the front of the metro i mean
in here they quote um down at the bottom
then the quote brush johnson saying that
the moment now is to accelerate so you
see what i'm kind of talking about in
terms of
you look at things the different
perspectives either this is a time to
accelerate or it's a time to be
cautious i think the government has kind
of played both those
lines and again and again across the
space of the last year
of not exactly mixed messaging but kind
of leaving themselves open to have all
avenues which okay as steve sings maybe
is fair enough but i mean the thing that
makes it different from christmas
now today is that we have a huge amount
more data and crucially we
we can't underplay not just the success
of the vaccine
in protecting the elderly and the
vulnerable and
you know getting us to the position that
we are now where we can see a light at
the end of the tunnel
but actually being the reasoning behind
the light at the end of the tunnel
because the whole point of
lockdown restrictions wasn't to
eliminate coronavirus from the
population completely it was based on a
fact of what's always been about the
very noble
and very sensible aim of protecting the
section of our society for which this
virus proves
you know fatal deadly and and can make
people really ill
and so once you have a certain amount of
that you know the right amount the safe
amount of that section of society
they're saying
the line top priorities on the priority
list
vaccinated then the pressure is on to
start lifting restrictions and i mean
the
letter from the covered recovery group
you know headed up by steve baker
60th or so tory mp's pressurizing
the government to make promises that
they will begin to
rapidly revert back on some of the laws
um that have been instituted
criminalizing normal behavior for good
reason
over the last year and that to me seems
eminently sensible because it's not like
christmas where we're just kind of
taking a punt
we now have the hardcore data and the
kind of
a different position of being sure and
the knowledge that we have
had this vaccine roll out and that it
has been successful and so let's keep it
moving yeah
let's have a look at the front of the
manchester evening news because they
have
a reminder that we are far from uh
over this crisis and still patients keep
on coming
is uh their headline they've done an
investigation on the front line
of hospitals in manchester and steve i
suppose it's worth making the point that
the public
support the restrictions still report
for lockdown is still
support for lockdown it's still very
high isn't it amongst the amongst the
public
yeah and unsurprisingly in my view i
don't think
on the whole voters have this kind of
libertarian streak and horror
of uh kind of state intervention that
a group of boris johnson's parliamentary
party clearly has i mean obviously there
are issues about the economy
but in the end it is the virus that's
wrecking the economy not the
measures aimed at dealing with the virus
and it was interesting reading we got
the papers in first of all about this
must be the last lockdown
vaccine targets met etc and then you get
that
paper in outside london with a reminder
of the level of hospital missions still
being high and i was very struck hearing
one of the
many scientists that dominate the
airwaves these days
saying that the hospital admissions are
such that if we weren't in lockdown
now we would have to go into lockdown so
although the vaccine news is fantastic
and potentially liberating we're not
through this yet and that was a
it's an interesting contrast as
incidentally other stories about
the chaos at airports as this attempt to
quarantine people coming into the uk
tries to come into effect so this is
still
a multi-layer challenge on many levels
and ella why don't we we finish on that
point about uh quarantine hotels because
they started as well
today um and uh you know there are
concerns that they won't
work necessarily i mean already there's
a great deal of criticism about how
they've been planned and
and how they're operating well it's one
of those things that in practice
it seems eminently sensible to manage
and control
uh who comes into the country on the
basis of these red lists because of the
nature of
fears of new strains and the way in
which this viruses
seems to be working but in that in
theory i mean that kind of seems
sensible but in practice
what's happened is a kind of uh would
you call it scattergun
certainly seems to be a rather rash
decision to implement these and
without any kind of uh most people are
saying well i've had
one two tests they've come back negative
why am i
then still being penalized there seems
to be a kind of as has been with many
things throughout this
uh lockdown period lockdown periods over
the last year
a kind of blanket approach to something
which could deal with could do with a
bit more of a focused approach
and you know people are complaining
about the price obviously people are
also complaining about being stir crazy
i'm not opposed to quarantine in
principle because i think it's a good
tool in order to
stop the spread of virus and maintain
some control over what's going on in
relation to the virus entering the
country
or not entering the country but it does
seem like another one of these things
that's been implemented rashly
and in practice seems to be causing a
lot of pain for people who don't
necessarily need to be in quarantine why
if you've taken several
tests and they've all come back negative
does it make any sense to keep people in
quarantine
okay well we'll uh uh lots more to
discuss
after the break for now ella and steve
thank you very much indeed
coming up couple expecting a baby to go
on tv talk show uh well that's one way
of looking at it i suppose we'll have
more on that
hello again part two of the press
preview ella and steve still
with us uh steve let's look out front of
the guardian dominic cummings he's out
of downing street but he's still in the
papers
yeah he is and this is a story of
considerable significance beyond
actually dominic cummings
it's about the government awarding
contracts
uh in that sort of panic-stricken period
when they were trying to get equipment
over and all the rest of it this is a
specific contract
uh to accompany and i think dominic
cummings justifies it because they
needed to get opinion and
focus groups and all the rest of it done
who happened to be
run by former colleagues or friends of
his but a huge amount of this
went on the government's defense is
uh it was an emergency and it was all
hands to the pump but
a pattern has recurred frequently
of huge amounts of money in inverted
commas
taxpayers money being doled out
indiscriminately it seems
to um friends of or former colleagues of
uh people within number 10 and the
cabinet and so on
and uh this is now i think becoming
a sort of bigger story and it's it's
it's made the front page of the
guardian but i think it will be a
recurring theme
especially when an inquiry is conducted
into what happened
in the spring of last year specifically
the as part of the broader inquiry
yeah in a witness statement dominic
cummings says obviously i did not
request public first be brought in
because they were my friends
it was the only company with the
expertise to carry out the required
focus
groups urgently and ella i mean the
government was using these emergency
regulations which they were entitled to
do
yes they were entitled to and on the
well on the basis of setting their
own rules around it i think the thing
that makes this so
irksome is not just the kind of
pointless statements from cummings that
he promises he but this wasn't about
and benefiting friends but because the
reliance on
focus groups for example tells you
something about the fact that the
government might have blown all this
money
on asking the public in this very kind
of cummings-like way
of sort of behind closed doors kind of
managing how people behave
when in actual fact the one thing that's
been really important parliamentary
scrutiny whether it be about how things
like this
get done or what new laws get passed
what regulations are going to be in
place next week
has been severely lacking so in terms of
actually having public engagement in
uh the law making process in politics in
general over the last year has been
we've been kind of absent yes for you
know understandable reasons because
we're in an emergency
but when things like this come to light
it makes it all the more
it showed it reveals actually the bigger
problem which is that there has been a
tendency to rely on things like focus
groups or polls
you know rather than actually having the
proper means through which democracy is
meant to
work okay let's finish with a story on
the front of the daily star we've been
reporting this as well this evening
uh quite an interesting quite a clever
headline really this might cause a bit
of a kerfuffle publicity shy couple to
tell all to oprah
yes really and there's a picture of
harry and megan there with their eyes
blacked out
steve what do you what do you make of
all this
i think it raises the question what is
celebrity in this modern age i remember
woody allen in an interview once saying
that in america
if someone gets kidnapped and emerges
safe he's offered a chat show or she's
offered a chat show
and this duo who no longer can claim to
be
royal even though that begs questions
about what is
celebrity being born into a family but
they're not even that so
on what basis do they claim this
uh platform uh and there is no clear
answer to that
that they have a platform i've got no
doubt no doubt there will be a huge
audience for this
interview um but it's a good cover
because publicity shy is not quite what
they are whatever they are
what will the queen make of this ella oh
who knows
it's good fodder for the crown isn't it
but one of the things i mean i just this
is the brilliant thing about british
newspapers there have been discussions
about consent and some people are saying
the difference here is that she's
consented to it
i don't quite buy that i think that
steve's right this is a couple that are
particularly engaged in pursuit of
celebrity
but one thing you have to say about
british newspapers is they know how to
make a joke there's been several
uh engagements of mickey taking on the
on the
at the pair's expense you know you can't
you can't shy away from publicity when
you don't want it and then try and
flaunt it when you do and
i don't think the british public is
quite good at tearing people down
sometimes for bad reasons but sometimes
when they deserve it
ella steve i must leave it there thank
you both